so I I dated this guy named Jeff briefly
and he had just gotten out of a
relationship with this psycho chick
named Tiffany this is maybe a month or
two into seeing each other and the
responses I was getting back from Jeff
in text didn't sound like him like there
was like really poor grammar and just it
just didn't sound like him So eventually
I said hey like am I really texting with
Jeff and I got a response and text that
said no this is his girl I'd appreciate
it if you never spoke to him again I
just decided that point like well both
of them then I'm gonna I'm gonna burn
this whole thing to the ground so I sent
a text back to Tiffany that said haha
Kelly you're so funny you and Jeff and I
should have another threesome soon yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
I bet you Tiffany got on her dirt bike
did a real all the way to Jeff's out
foreign